how do people deal with negative
self-talk
okay negative self-talk unfortunately is
part of human life
there is indeed something of a
negativity bias built into us as human
beings
because let's face it for the vast
majority of human existence on the
planet
our lives were rather uncertain
we did not necessarily know
where the food supply was going to come
from
a month down the line
our existence was somewhat fragile and
unpredictable so we developed as a
survival mechanism this tendency to kind
of worry about stuff because it
energized us to be careful
okay
now
a lot of that negativity bias is
unnecessary but we still have it
and it's very important for
everyone who wants to become a more
confident individual to be honest about
where indeed does that negative voice
kick in does it kick in when i enter the
office of my boss does it kick in when i
enter um the weight room does it kick in
on you know game day morning
when and where does it kick in
let's get let's get some awareness about
that
once we have that awareness
now let's be very good
at
talking back to that voice
again this is a choice that you make
this voice kicks in oh i don't know if
i've done enough practice
you have to acknowledge that you have to
acknowledge that right now your
confidence is under attack
it's kind of like you're in the boxing
match and here comes a punch
you better acknowledge it and your
second step after you've acknowledged it
is to stop it
everybody has the ability to shut that
voice off maybe you need to visualize a
stop sign maybe you need to visualize a
red traffic light
maybe and this is a somewhat humorous
example
you need to visualize a toilet being
flushed
we all know what
goes down the tubes there but that's a
representation of stopping it getting
rid of it
and then third
really important you got to get in the
last word
you've got to talk back to that voice
you've got to say no i have done this
practice and this practice and this
practice and this is where your
journaled mental bank account comes in
really handy
you can draw from it in those moments
and the same way you get the last word
in during an argument
with your obnoxious older or younger
sibling
you get the word in against that
voice of negativity and fear and doubt
and that momentarily silences it gives
you an opportunity to be present with
what you're doing
now you may have to repeat that process
acknowledge it stop it replace it
two minutes down the road
you may have to do it over and over
again and that's fine
as long as you are acknowledging it
stopping it and replacing it getting in
that last word you are in the game
you're winning that mental battle
you are accomplishing what i refer to in
the book as a first victory
victory over your mind
that gives you an opportunity and please
remember
all your competitors all your opponents
they've got just as much negative
self-talk as you have
if you're just a little bit better at
acknowledging it stopping it replacing
it
then those competitors are those
opponents wow you just created an
advantage for yourself
so look at it that way gang what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you